I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello everybody. How are you guys? I have some big news that I want to share with you, Angela. What? Remember when we talked about my long crotch pants? How could I forget? Long crotch? I had them altered. Oh, you had your crotch altered. Well, I had the waist altered. Oh, okay. I took an inch out of the back of the waist. And now they fit your crotch right? Yep,
我是珍娜·菲舍。我是安吉拉·金西。我們曾一起出演《辦公室瘋雲》。而且我們是最好的朋友。現在我們專門為你們製作了這個《辦公室瘋雲》終極重溫播客。每週我們都會剖析一集《辦公室瘋雲》，並分享只有親歷其境的兩個人才能告訴你的獨家幕後故事。我們是辦公室女士。大家好。你們好嗎？安吉拉，我有個重磅消息想跟你分享。什麼？還記得我們上次討論我的長襠褲嗎？我怎麼會忘？長襠褲？我把它改過了。哦，你把襠部改了。嗯，我是把腰部改了。哦，好吧。我從後腰處剪掉了一英寸。然後現在你的褲襠合身了嗎？對，
I'm wearing them today. I wanted to show you. Stand up, let me see. She got the crotch right. She got the crotch right. Now it fits you right in the butt too. It does. Because before you had saggy bottom and long crotch. I know, but now I fixed it. And I, since I brought the problem to the pod, I thought I'd bring the solution to the pod. I'm here for it. Well, we have a very fun episode today. It is Crime Aid, Season 5, Episode 5, written by Charlie Grandy and directed by Jen Salata. Here's your summary. Pam is working at corporate in New York City to help pay for her life at art school. Holly and Michael take their relationship to the next level, resulting in a burglary at the office. Michael hosts an auction to recoup the valuables lost,
我今天就穿著它。我想讓你看看。站起來，讓我看看。她把褲襠改對了。她把褲襠改對了。現在連屁股那裡也合身了。確實合身。因為之前你的屁股看起來垮垮的，襠部又很長。我知道，但現在我把它改好了。而且，既然我把這個問題帶到了播客裡，我想我也應該把解決方案帶到播客裡。我太支援了。好吧，我們今天有一集非常有趣的節目。它是《犯罪援助》，第五季第五集，由查理·格蘭迪編劇，珍·薩拉塔導演。以下是劇情梗概：潘在紐約的總公司工作，以支付她在藝術學校的生活費。霍莉和邁克爾將他們的關係推進到了一個新階段，結果導致辦公室遭到了入職盜竊。邁克爾主持了一場拍賣會來挽回丟失的貴重物品，
and Dwight turns to Phyllis for advice on how to win Angela back. I loved everything Dwight and Phyllis. What a great combo. That's the thing the writers did. They like to mix it up. I was here for it. I absolutely loved it as well. That moves me in to Fast Fact number one. Do it. New writer alert. New writer alert. Charlie Grandy. Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding. It's another new writer alert. So before working on the office, Charlie was a stand-up comedian, and he wrote for The Daily Show with John Stuart and Saturday Night Live. He's super funny. Super funny. After the office, he went on to write for the Mindy Project. And Angela, Charlie said that one of the main inspirations for this episode was to highlight Phyllis. Charlie, you did it, and I love that you
而德懷特向菲利斯尋求如何重新贏回安吉拉的建議。我喜歡所有德懷特和菲利斯的橋段。多麼棒的組合。這就是編劇們的拿手好戲。他們喜歡把不同的人混搭在一起。我太支援了。我也非常喜歡。這就讓我進入了第一條趣事。說吧。新編劇警報。新編劇警報。查理·格蘭迪。叮，叮，叮，叮，叮。又是一個新編劇警報。所以在加入《辦公室瘋雲》之前，查理是一名棟篤笑喜劇演員，他曾為喬恩·斯圖爾特的《每日秀》和《週六夜現場》寫過劇本。他超級搞笑。超級搞笑。離開《辦公室瘋雲》後，他繼續為《明迪煩事多》擔任編劇。安吉拉，查理說這一集的主要靈感之一就是為了突顯菲利斯。查理，你做到了，而且我很高興你
love Phyllis. Yeah, he said this was one of those situations where they wanted to do a storyline with an unusual pairing. Remember, they used to just put people's names on cards and pair them up? This was Dwight Phyllis. I love it. This is what happens when you put the Dwight and Phyllis cards together. You know what card never came together? What? Jim Angela. You're so right. You're so right. Fast Fact number two. This is the first episode that Jen Solata directed. Oh, Jen, that's right. Yeah. I mean, guys, it was so much fun to have Jen on set. She was such a laugher. She was such a blast. She was also one of the showrunners this season with Pauley Bernstein. She'd been on the show for a while. And I don't know if you remember, but during Beach
喜歡菲利斯。是的，他說這就是那種他們想要用不尋常的組合來創作一條故事線的情況。還記得嗎，他們以前只是把大家的名字寫在卡片上然後隨機配對？這對就是德懷特和菲利斯。我太喜歡了。這就是當你把德懷特和菲利斯的卡片放在一起時發生的事情。你知道哪張卡片從來沒有組合過嗎？什麼？吉姆和安吉拉。你太對了。你說得太對了。第二條趣事。這是珍·薩拉塔導演的第一集。哦，珍，沒錯。是的。我的意思是，夥計們，有珍在片場真的太有趣了。她特別愛笑。她真是個開心果。這一季她還和保利·伯恩斯坦一起擔任了節目統籌。她已經在劇組待了一陣子了。我不知道你們是否還記得，但在《海灘
Games, she talked about how Harold Ramis really encouraged her to direct one day. Yeah. And this was kind of the... That moment. Yeah. This was where it led. So we reached out to Jen and we have some really fun stuff to sprinkle through the episode. I asked her specifically, okay, what was it like directing your first episode? And she said the thing that really stressed her out the most was that she thought directors had to have all the answers. She was really worried that someone would ask her a question about a prop or how to set up a scene and that she wouldn't know. And she said someone gave her the advice to just kind of like fake it till you make it sort of thing. But Jen was like, I can't. I can't fake it. If I don't know something, I'm gonna shout
遊戲》那一集，她談到哈羅德·雷米斯是如何真正鼓勵她有一天去當導演的。是的。而這差不多就是……那個時刻。是的。這就是這一切的由來。所以我們聯絡了珍，我們有一些非常有趣的事情要在這集節目中穿插。我專門問她，好吧，導演你的第一集是什麼感覺？她說真正讓她壓力最大的事情是，她認為導演必須知道所有答案。她真的很擔心有人會問她關於道具或如何佈置場景的問題，而她卻答不上來。她說有人給她的一個建議就是「假裝直到你成功」的那種心態。但珍卻覺得：我做不到。我無法假裝。如果我不知道某件事，我就會大聲喊出
out. I don't know. Well, Jen wears every emotion across her face, right? You know how Jen feels about something. Well, I have to say, I really respect a person who says I don't know. I do, too. I don't need fake it till you make it. I would much rather just know truly how someone's feeling. I don't need like the whatever, yeah, thing the filter people put on. I agree. Well, she also said that Jeff Blitz gave her the advice. Don't worry if you don't sleep the night before your first day of shooting. No director sleeps the night before and your adrenaline will kick in. And she said that was absolutely true. She did not sleep. And her adrenaline did kick in. So she was good. I bet I can't sleep like before a big day ever. I'm like up all through the night.
我不知道。好吧，珍把所有的情緒都寫在臉上了，對吧？你知道珍對某事的感受。嗯，我必須說，我真的很尊重一個敢說「我不知道」的人。我也是。我不需要什麼「假裝直到成功」。我寧願真正瞭解一個人的真實感受。我不需要那些什麼亂七八糟的、別人套上的濾鏡。我同意。嗯，她還說傑夫·布里茨給過她一個建議：不用擔心你在拍攝第一天前的那天晚上睡不着覺。沒有哪個導演在拍攝前一晚能睡着，你的腎上腺素會飆升。而她說這絕對是真的。她確實沒睡着。她的腎上腺素也確實飆升了。所以她狀態很好。我敢說我在任何重大日子的前一晚都睡不着。我整晚都醒着。
I know. That happens to me as an actor the night before my first day on a new project, especially. I'm so nervous. The day before a big trip. I'm always like, okay, did I pack my charger? Got it. Underwear. I don't know. Did I pack underwear? I don't know. I don't know. Oh, my God, I got to get up. I got to look. I can't like sleep the night before anything big. All right, are you ready for fast fact number three? Yes. Roy is back. Oh, yes, he is. He comes back in this episode. And it's a huge surprise. It's so well done. The writers said they were always looking for ways to bring David back. Well, I hadn't seen this episode in a long time. And when I watched it and he walked in, I was like, oh, Roy's here. And now he's with Jim. Oh, no,
我知道。作為一個演員，我在新項目第一天的前一晚也會這樣，尤其是這樣。我太緊張了。重大行程的前一天。我總是會想：好吧，我的充電器打包了嗎？拿到了。內衣。我不知道。我打包內衣了嗎？我不知道。我不知道。哦，天哪，我得起來。我得去看看。在任何大事的前一晚我都無法入睡。好了，你們準備好聽第三條趣事了嗎？是的。羅伊回來了。哦，沒錯，他回來了。他這一集又回來了。這真是一個巨大的驚喜。這集拍得太棒了。編劇們說他們一直在尋找讓大衛回來的方法。嗯，我已經很久沒看這集了。當我看到它，他走進來的時候，我想：哦，羅伊來了。而且現在他和吉姆……哦，不，
no, no. Like I completely forgot. I have a show Bible summary of Roy Anderson. Remember, we never did a show Bible goodbye for him. So I thought maybe let's remember Roy since we're gonna see him this week. Let's do it. Roy Anderson worked in the warehouse at Dunder Mifflin. He was engaged to Pam for three years. They went to high school together. He was on the football team, and he hoped they would go to Mexico for their honeymoon. He has wave runners that he bought with his brother, which they eventually sold at a loss. He has a truck. He would carpool to work with Pam. He thinks Angelo's kind of hot. He plays fantasy football, and he is eventually fired after he tries to attack Jim. He apologizes to Pam and moves on until this episode when he runs
不，不。就像我完全忘了一樣。我有一份關於羅伊·安德森的節目設定集摘要。記住，我們從來沒有為他做過節目設定集的告別。所以我想，既然我們這週會見到他，不如來回憶一下羅伊吧。我們開始吧。羅伊·安德森曾在鄧德米夫林的倉庫工作。他和潘訂婚了三年。他們一起上過高中。他是足球隊的隊員，他希望他們能去墨西哥度蜜月。他有和哥哥一起買的水上摩托艇，最後虧本賣掉了。他有一輛卡車。他會和潘拼車上班。他覺得安吉拉有點辣。他玩幻想足球，在試圖襲擊吉姆後最終被解僱。他向潘道歉並繼續前進，直到這集他在酒吧里遇到
into Jim at a bar, and it is revealed he's been working at Vitamin World. Vitamin Shop is what his shirt said. It did. I thought it said Vitamin World. It said Vitamin Shoppy, S-H-O-P-P-E. Hmm, I'm gonna revisit that, I guess. I'll take another look at his shirt, although I do believe you. Well, now I'm having that moment like, wait, I'm pretty sure it's Vitamin Shop. Oh, dear. Oh, Lord. Time code. We need a time code. Well, lady, that's all I got. I've got some fun tidbits. There was good deleted scenes for this one. All right. Well, should we take a break and then we'll get to it? Let's get to it. I like it. We are back, and Pam is working in an office. What's going on? Why isn't she in art school? I'm confused. It looks a lot like a paper company. Well,
吉姆，並且透露他一直在維生素世界工作。他的襯衫上寫的是維生素店。確實是。我以為上面寫的是維生素世界。上面寫的是Vitamin Shoppy，S-H-O-P-P-E。嗯，我想我得重新去確認一下了。我會再看一眼他的襯衫，儘管我相信你。好吧，現在我有那種感覺了，就像：等等，我很確信那是維生素店。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。時間碼。我們需要一個時間碼。好吧，女士們，我只有這些了。我有一些有趣的八卦。這一集有一些很棒的刪減片段。好吧。那我們要不要休息一下然後接着聊？我們開始吧。我喜歡。我們回來了，潘正在一個辦公室工作。怎麼回事？她為什麼不在藝術學校？我很困惑。這看起來很像一家造紙公司。嗯，
that's because it is. It is Dunder Mifflin Corporate. She gets a phone call. It's Michael. Of course it's Michael, because now he knows where she is. All the time. All the time. Well, he knows how to reach her part of the time, at least. There was a missing scene in this little runner of Pam working in New York. At one point, Michael's gonna call her and ask her for a slice of pizza. She's like, Michael. And she's like, Michael, if I get you a slice of pizza, will you stop calling? Basically. And then the next scene is Michael opening up like a FedEx package and there's one slice of pizza not wrapped in anything like loose. And he starts eating it and it's sort of come apart in the packaging. And he's so happy because he got his New York slice from Pam. I mean, that
那是因為它確實是。這是鄧德米夫林總公司。她接到了一個電話。是邁克爾。當然是邁克爾，因為現在他知道她在哪裡了。隨時隨地。隨時隨地。好吧，至少有時候他知道怎麼聯絡到她。這段潘在紐約工作的插曲裡有一個遺漏的片段。有一次，邁克爾打電話給她，向她要一塊披薩。她說：邁克爾。她說：邁克爾，如果我給你弄一塊披薩，你能不能別打電話了？基本上就是這樣。然後下一個鏡頭是邁克爾打開一個聯邦快遞的包裹，裡面有一塊沒有任何包裝、散落着的披薩。他開始吃起來，披薩在包裝里有點散開了。他高興壞了，因為他從潘那裡得到了他心心念念的紐約披薩。我的意思是，這
is so gross. How long did it take to get there? But I love the idea that Pam sort of passively, aggressively or whatever. I don't know. Mailed Michael a slice of pizza and he was delighted. It was deleted, unfortunately. Unfortunately. And poor Steve had to eat that pizza quite a bit. And he had huge bites of it. Like his cheeks were all full of pizza. Well, now we move into the episode and Michael and Holly arrive to work. They are glowing. Well, they've been super flirty. They've had two dates. And tonight, they're gonna go out and it's gonna be their third date. Yeah. And Michael says in America, the third date is usually when you have sex. And he hopes Holly agrees with that. If she starts having sex with me, I'll know for sure is what he says.
太噁心了。這花了多長時間才送到的？但我喜歡這種想法，就是潘有點被動攻擊或者隨便什麼。我不知道。給邁克爾寄了一塊披薩，而他高興壞了。不幸的是，這段被刪了。不幸的是。可憐的史蒂夫不得不吃那塊披薩好多次。而且他還咬了很大一口。就像他的腮幫子塞滿了披薩一樣。好吧，現在我們進入正題，邁克爾和霍莉去上班了。他們滿面春風。嗯，他們之前調情得厲害。他們已經約會兩次了。今晚，他們要出去約會，這將是他們的第三次約會。是的。邁克爾說在美國，第三次約會通常就是你發生性關係的時候。他希望霍莉也這麼認為。如果她開始跟我發生性關係，我就能百分之百確定了，他是這麼說的。
Yeah. So lady, Michael's whole thing where he's talking about the third date is when you have sex. I was intrigued because I remember the show Sex and the City. Well, yeah. Do you remember that? Of course. Okay. So in Sex and the City, there's this scene where Charlotte gives a big speech to the group of friends where she says she never has sex until the third date, no matter what. This is her rule. Okay. There was actually a book called The Rules that women were supposed to follow in order to like nab a man. I remember that book. Remember the rule? Oh, God. Right. I know. So crazy. So that was kind of, I think, the inspiration for this idea that you wait till the third date. And doesn't Michael love Sex and the City? He does love Sex and the City. So I
是的。所以女士們，邁克爾關於第三次約會就是發生性關係的整段言論。我很感興趣，因為我記得《慾望城市》這部劇。嗯，是的。你還記得嗎？當然記得。好吧。所以在《慾望城市》裡有這樣一個場景：夏洛特對着一群朋友發表了一場慷慨激昂的演講，她說她無論如何都不會在第三次約會之前發生性關係。這是她的原則。好吧。實際上有一本書叫《規則》，女性被要求遵循這些規則來釣到一個男人。我記得那本書。還記得那個規則嗎？哦，天哪。沒錯。我知道。太瘋狂了。所以我覺得這大概就是「等到第三次約會」這個想法的靈感來源。而且邁克爾難道不喜歡《慾望城市》嗎？他確實很喜歡《慾望城市》。所以我
think that's what he is quoting Charlotte. Yeah, he's quoting Charlotte. Except he's twisted it. Yeah, to America. Charlotte is like, I never have sex till the third date. And Michael is like, I get laid on the third date. Yeah. That's how he heard that. Well, it got me curious. I googled, is there an ideal amount of time to date before sex? Okay, this is what's so funny is that I started to lick this up and I was like, I just have a feeling Jenna's going to lick this up. I looked it up. Are you ready for what I found? Oh, no. Go. It was super interesting. It was similar to our sex timer conversation. There was a Groupon survey of 2000 adults in the United States. Wait, Groupon? Groupon. Like what you signed up for to get like better tickets to Disneyland? Like Groupon? Yeah. I was so confused
想他這是在引用夏洛特的話。是的，他是在引用夏洛特。只不過他把它給歪曲了。是的，把它套用到美國。夏洛特的意思是：我直到第三次約會才發生性關係。而邁克爾的意思是：我在第三次約會時就能上床。是的。他是這麼理解的。這引起了我的好奇。我在谷歌上搜尋了：在發生性關係之前，最佳的約會時間是多久？好吧，最好笑的是，我開始查這個的時候心想：我有種直覺，珍娜一定會去查這個。我查了。準備好聽我發現了什麼嗎？哦，不。說吧。這超級有趣。這和我們之前關於性愛計時器的對話很像。Groupon（團購網）對美國2000名成年人進行了一項調查。等等，Groupon？Groupon。就像你註冊來獲取迪士尼樂園更好門票的那種網站？就像Groupon？
why Groupon was asking people this question. Okay. But it's their survey. They wanted to know how long people waited to have sex with a new partner. Now, I'm just saying, if your Groupon app like sent you this question, would you answer it? I would not answer. I'd be like Groupon, this is not your best group on staying in your lane. Yeah. Well, here's their result. The average answer was eight dates with women waiting nine and men waiting five. They also found that men were nine times more likely to be okay with having sex on the first date. Yeah, I think. All right. Have a new study. Okay. Here's the other study. This one feels a little bit more legit. Oh, it's not Groupon? It's not Groupon. You don't get free steak if like eight of you sign up? What other surveys has Groupon
是的。我當時很困惑為什麼Groupon會問人們這個問題。好吧。但這是他們的調查。他們想知道人們在與新伴侶發生性關係前等待了多久。現在，我只想說，如果你的Groupon應用程式給你發送了這個問題，你會回答嗎？我不會回答。我會覺得：Groupon，這不是你的強項，Groupon，管好你自己的事吧。好吧，這是他們的結果。平均答案是八次約會，其中女性等待九次，男性等待五次。他們還發現，男性在第一次約會就接受性關係的可能性是女性的九倍。好吧，我有個新研究。好的。這是另一個研究。這個聽起來好像稍微靠譜一點。哦，不是Groupon？不是Groupon。如果你們八個人一起註冊，難道還能拿到免費牛排嗎？Groupon還做過什麼其他調查？
been having? Sex therapists of America log on to Groupon. Oh my gosh. All right. This one is from the Journal of Sex Research. Sounds a little bit more official. No offense Groupon. Also may be made up, but they analyzed nearly 11,000 unmarried adults who were in serious or steady relationships. Okay. They asked them, at what point in your relationship did you have sex? 51% waited a few weeks. 38% had sex either on the first date or within two weeks. 11% had sex before their first date. What? How do you do that? I don't know. Like they had sex and then they went on a date. Oh my gosh. Yeah. So this isn't exactly saying number of dates, but more like period of time. Okay. They also found that the timing of people's first sexual encounter did not
美國性治療師協會登錄Groupon。哦，天哪。好吧。這項研究來自《性研究期刊》。聽起來稍微官方一點。無意冒犯Groupon。也可能是編造的，但他們分析了近11000名處於認真或穩定關係中的未婚成年人。好的。他們問這些人：你們在關係發展到什麼階段時發生了性關係？51%的人等待了幾周。38%的人在第一次約會時或兩周內發生了性關係。11%的人在第一次約會前就發生了性關係。什麼？這怎麼可能？我不知道。就像他們先發生了性關係，然後才去約會。哦，天哪。是的。所以這並不是確切地指約會次數，而是指一段時間。好吧。他們還發現，人們第一次性接觸的時間長短並不會從根本上對他們長遠的關係感受
impact their feelings about the relationship in the long run in a meaningful way. So everybody was happy whether they banged before their first date or three weeks later. That booked the rules on how to nab your man. That would just throw their theories out the window. Yeah, that's right. Journal of Sex Research. There was one thing. They said that the people who had sex earlier tended to be slightly less satisfied now in their relationship. Oh. So there was nothing to like look forward to? Well, that was one of their theories. One of the theories was that since they'd been having sex longer, you know, that early sex was maybe more exciting. And since they'd been at it for a bit longer, since they started earlier, maybe it's lost its shine. I don't know. Everything I read,
產生實質性的影響。所以無論他們是在第一次約會前還是三周後發生關係，大家都很開心。那本關於如何釣到男人的《規則》書。那簡直會把他們的理論徹底粉碎。是的，沒錯。《性研究期刊》。不過還有一點。他們說，那些更早發生性關係的人，在目前的關係中往往會稍微沒那麼滿意。哦。所以就沒有什麼好期待的了？嗯，那是他們的理論之一。其中一個理論是，既然他們發生性關係的時間更長了，你知道的，早期那種性愛可能更刺激一些。而既然他們已經進行了一段時間，因為開始得更早，也許那種新鮮感已經消失了。我不知道。我讀到的所有內容，
Ange said, the best thing you can do is figure out what sex means to you. If sex means physical pleasure, then find someone who agrees. If sex means I'm in a committed relationship, find a partner that agrees. And then you'll have like a really good sexual encounter. That was the advice. Well, Jenna, at the end of all of your research, I have found nuggets from Groupon and the Sex Journal people. What? Journal of Sex Research. Thank you. All good nuggets there. Yeah. Well, listen, while Michael was obsessed with the idea that he might get to have sex tonight, Andy is passing out save the date cards. Andy is excited because he's getting married. He's very excited. He's calling everyone like D-Money, J-Money. At two minutes, 44 seconds, Dwight opens this
安吉，都說你能做的最好的事情就是弄清楚性對你而言意味着什麼。如果性意味着生理上的快樂，那就去找一個意見一致的人。如果性意味着我處於一段承諾關係中，那就找一個意見一致的伴侶。然後你們就會有一段非常美好的性體驗。這就是建議。好吧，珍娜，在你進行了所有的研究之後，我找到了來自Groupon和性研究學會的精華。什麼？《性研究期刊》。謝謝。那裡都是好乾貨。是的。好吧，聽着，當邁克爾沉迷於今晚可能會有性愛的時候，安迪正在分發「保留日期」卡片。安迪很興奮，因為他要結婚了。他非常興奮。他管每個人叫D-Money、J-Money。在兩分四十四秒的時候，德懷特打開了這張
invitation. He's clearly concerned that there's a save the date. When he opens the envelope, all this confetti comes out. I know. And Reign's reaction is Dwight to it was so funny. But that is my husband's reaction to it. We were invited to a baby shower and we opened the envelope. Now, listen, I'm expecting the confetti and some wedding invitations now. It's become a thing, right? You open the envelope and little wedding bells and things come out of it. I was not expecting confetti out of a baby shower. We opened the envelope and my husband doesn't open anything gently. So we kind of tore into the envelope and all these little bitty baby bottles and baby carriages and little things just like flew up in the air. And my husband was like, why do they do
請柬。很明顯，他看到這是一張「保留日期」卡片時有些擔憂。當他打開信封時，所有的五彩紙屑都噴了出來。我知道。雷恩對此的反應，德懷特對此的反應太搞笑了。但這正是我丈夫的反應。我們曾受邀去參加一個迎嬰派對，然後我們打開了信封。現在，聽着，我現在對五彩紙屑和一些結婚請柬已經有所心理準備了。這已經成了一種常態，對吧？你打開信封，然後小婚禮鐘和其他小東西就會飛出來。我可沒料到一個迎嬰派對會噴出五彩紙屑。我們打開了信封，我丈夫從來不溫柔地打開任何東西。所以我們有點撕開了信封，然後所有這些小小的奶瓶、嬰兒車和小物件就直接飛到了空中。我丈夫就說：他們為什麼要這麼做？
that? I'm with Josh. Welcome to my wedding as I make a mess on your floor. I mean, I'm already I'm annoyed by your wedding or your baby shower. It cracked me up. You know what I mean? Don't mess up my house while you invite me to something. Don't mess up my area with your festivities. Yeah, I don't know. I don't know. I'm on the fence about it. Part of me thought it was fun and the other part was like, Oh, no, I got to clean that up. Yeah, I always lean toward I have to clean it up. Well, we're about to have a little bit of what I call breaking the wall in the break room. Talk to me about it. Are you confused? Slightly. Three minutes, three seconds. While Dwight is woodling a knife with a knife. While Dwight is woodling a knife with a knife. Phyllis wants to know if
我站在喬什這邊。歡迎來到我的婚禮，順便我在你地板上製造了一團糟。我的意思是，我已經對你的婚禮或迎嬰派對感到煩惱了。這把我逗樂了。你知道我的意思嗎？在我受邀參加某個活動時，別把我的房子弄得一團糟。別用你的慶祝活動把我的區域弄得亂七八糟的。好吧，我不知道。我對此持觀望態度。一方面我覺得挺有趣的，另一方面又覺得：哦，不，我得把那清理乾淨。是的，我總是傾向於：我得把它清理乾淨。好吧，我們即將迎來一個我稱之為在茶水間「打破第四堵牆」的橋段。跟我聊聊這個。你覺得困惑嗎？有一點。三分三秒。當德懷特正在用一把小刀雕刻一把小刀的時候。當德懷特正在用一把小刀雕刻一把小刀的時候。菲利斯想知道他是否還好。
he's okay. Does he want to talk about it? And she looks right at camera. She goes, you know, I know, you know, they know. Phyllis, sassy Phyllis. Yeah, breaking that fourth wall and bringing the camera crew into it. Yeah. And this is the beginning of that delicious Dwight Phyllis runner. Yes, that is going to play out so beautifully. At the same time, Michael and Holly are planning their date. Well, Michael just blurts out. They're talking about where they're going to eat. Maybe they go to the food court and he's like, well, I mean, it depends if we're going to have sex later. And then he was like, ah, and then I mean, this is like how you know Holly is his soulmate. I mean, I know we see it over and over again, but she's like, hell yeah. I know you're so worried that Michael
他想聊聊嗎？然後她直接看着鏡頭。她說：你知道的，我知道，你懂的，他們都知道。菲利斯，厚臉皮的菲利斯。是的，打破第四堵牆，把攝製組也帶進了這個情境中。是的。這就是那段精彩的德懷特和菲利斯支線劇情的開始。是的，這段劇情將會演繹得如此美妙。與此同時，邁克爾和霍莉正在計劃他們的約會。好吧，邁克爾直接脫口而出。他們正在談論去哪裡吃晚飯。也許他們去美食廣場，然後他說：嗯，我的意思是，這取決於我們稍後是否要發生性關係。然後他說：啊，接着我的意思是，這就是你如何知道霍莉是他的靈魂伴侶。我的意思是，我知道我們一次又一次地看到這一點，但她卻說：太棒了。我知道你很擔心邁克爾
has messed it up. Yeah. But he didn't because it's his soulmate. It's his soulmate. So at three minutes, 17 seconds for our background catch folks. Did you see the Taco Bandito menu? No, I didn't see it. Yeah, it's over Holly's shoulder. I looked it up. That is an actual restaurant in Scranton. It's on 211 North Main Avenue in Scranton. And that was Phyllis Shea getting us all those menus. Yes. Thanks to his in from Carrie Bennett, our wardrobe designer. That's right. Taco Bandito. Working together to make it specific. Well, Michael is super excited about the fact that Holly is on board third date sex. He has a talking head where he says he'll probably get soup. You know, something light. Yeah. Well, Jenna, there were some deleted scenes that really showed how once
搞砸了。是的。但他沒有搞砸，因為她是他的靈魂伴侶。她是他的靈魂伴侶。所以在三分十七秒的時候，給我們這些關注背景的觀眾們。你們看到Taco Bandito（塔可強盜）的菜單了嗎？不，我沒看到。是的，就在霍莉的肩膀上方。我查了一下。那是斯克蘭頓的一家真實餐廳。位於斯克蘭頓北主大街211號。那是菲利斯·謝伊為我們弄來的所有菜單。是的。多虧了我們的服裝設計師凱瑞·貝內特的內線消息。沒錯。Taco Bandito。齊心協力讓它變得如此具體。好吧，邁克爾對霍莉答應了第三次約會性愛這件事感到超級興奮。他有一個單人採訪鏡頭，說他可能會點湯。你知道的，一些清淡的東西。嗯，珍娜，有一些被刪減的片段真正展現了
Holly says hell yeah, Michael cannot think about anything else the rest of the day. I believe it. He is so distracted because he knows that he's going to have sex with Holly. There is a scene between Michael, Daryl and Angela. Like I never had scenes with Daryl and Michael. And Daryl and Angela are going over the warehouse budget. And Michael is just zoned out thinking about Holly. Sam, can you play it? The pallet truck's got a busted caster. We still waiting on our safety goggles. And we need a new forklift. Well, I can take maintenance cash and put it in the supply budget. If Michael's okay with it. Michael, do you approve that? Oh, yeah. Fine. Also, we have gnomes living in the wall. You mean rats? No. I mean, a little scary man with red hats.
一旦霍莉說了「太棒了」，邁克爾在剩餘的一整天裡就再也無法思考其他任何事情了。我相信。他太分心了，因為他知道自己要和霍莉發生性關係了。邁克爾、達里爾和安吉拉之間有一場戲。就像我以前從未和達里爾和邁克爾有過對手戲一樣。達里爾和安吉拉正在審查倉庫預算。而邁克爾完全神遊天外，滿腦子都在想霍莉。薩姆，你能播放一下嗎？托盤搬運車的腳輪壞了。我們還在等安全護目鏡嗎？我們需要一輛新的叉車。好吧，我可以動用維護現金把它放進供應預算里。如果邁克爾不介意的話。邁克爾，你批准嗎？哦，好。好的。另外，我們牆裡住着小矮人。你是說老鼠？不。我是說，戴着紅帽子的可怕小矮人。
I think they're drinking all our soda pop. You okay with that, Mike? Soda pop. Soda pop. I don't get it. Jenna, in the whole meeting, all he can say is hell yeah. And soda pop. And he's just looks so goofy through the whole meeting. Like Holly has just said hell yeah. And that's all Michael can process. Hell yeah. Angela, I really liked this scene in the break room between Dwight and Phyllis when Dwight is telling Phyllis all of the things that Angela taught him in life, his time with her. Angela introduced him to pasteurized milk, to sheets, to presents on your birthday, and preventative medicine. And monotheism. And monotheism. Look at all the things you've done. And then Dwight, he finally breaks down. He gets a little vulnerable. He's like, why is she marrying
我覺得他們在喝我們所有的蘇打水。你覺得這樣行嗎，邁克？蘇打水。蘇打水。我不明白。珍娜，在整個會議期間，他唯一能說的就是「太棒了」和「蘇打水」。他在整個會議期間看起來都傻乎乎的。就像霍莉剛剛說了「太棒了」，而這就是邁克爾唯一能處理的信息。太棒了。安吉拉，我真的很喜歡茶水間里德懷特和菲利斯之間的這場戲，當時德懷特正在告訴菲利斯安吉拉在生活中教給他的所有事情，他與她在一起的時光。安吉拉把他引進了巴氏殺菌奶、床單、生日禮物和預防醫學的世界。還有嚴格的一神教。還有嚴格的一神教。看看你做過的所有事情。然後德懷特，他終於崩潰了。他變得有點脆弱。他說：她為什麼要嫁給
him? And Phyllis says Angela's not much of a risk taker and Andy's not really a risk. She summed it up perfectly. She did. Angela took a risk on Dwight and she loved him and he put her cat in the freezer. She's not going to do that again. She's not. Well, Jenna, there was a deleted scene between Dwight and Phyllis that would just further this sort of conversation. But I'm sure it got cut for time. I saw it in the script and it was so funny. It's so funny. And they did actually shoot it. And it is in the deleted scenes. So this conversation continues. Dwight and Phyllis are now in the parking lot. They're on the bench by the warehouse and Dwight is eating a huge sandwich and they're talking. And Dwight shares with Phyllis what he and Angela did on their very
那個男人？菲利斯說安吉拉不是個愛冒險的人，而安迪也不是真的會冒險。她完美地概括了這一點。她確實如此。安吉拉曾為德懷特冒險，她愛過他，而他把她的貓塞進了冷凍庫。她不會再那樣做了。她不會的。好吧，珍娜，德懷特和菲利斯之間本來還有一場被刪減的戲，這會進一步推動這種對話。但我確信它是為了控制片長而被剪掉了。我在劇本里看到了，真的太搞笑了。太搞笑了。而且他們確實把這場戲拍了無特。它確實出現在刪減片段中。所以這段對話仍在繼續。德懷特和菲利斯現在在停車場。他們坐在倉庫旁邊的長椅上，德懷特正在吃一個巨大的三明治，他們一邊交談。德懷特與菲利斯分享了他和安吉拉在他們的第一次
first date. This is so funny to me. Here's what their first date was. They went to the anthracite Cole Museum tour. Yes. Yeah. Even though they had both been several times, they pretended like they'd never been so they could get all the extra information and special perks of the tour from the tour guide. Even though the tour guides recognized both of them because they'd been there so many times. And then he said, yeah, and we corrected them when they got their information wrong. Talk about soulmates. Soulmates. These two want to go to the anthracite Cole Museum tour, which they've done before so that they can tell the tour guide when they get things wrong. Well, I looked it up and Jenna, there is a Pennsylvania Anthracite Heritage Museum. The museum is part
約會時做過的事情。這對我來說太搞笑了。他們的第一次約會是這樣的。他們去了無煙煤煤炭博物館參觀。是的。是的。儘管他們兩個都已經去過好幾次了，但他們假裝從沒去過，這樣他們就能從導遊那裡得到所有的額外信息和導遊的特別優待。儘管導遊認出了他們兩個，因為他們去過太多次了。然後他說：對，當他們的信息搞錯時，我們還糾正了他們。談到靈魂伴侶。靈魂伴侶。這兩人想去無煙煤煤炭博物館參觀，他們以前去過那裡，這樣他們就可以在導遊弄錯事情時告訴導遊。好吧，我查了一下，珍娜，這裡確實有一個賓夕法尼亞無煙煤遺產博物館。該博物館是
of an anthracite museum complex created in 1971 by the Pennsylvania Historical and Museum Commission, but lady, there's three. There are three museums and one historical site located in their communities. Jenna, maybe put this on our list of places to go. Okay. The Pennsylvania Anthracite Heritage Museum and Scranton Iron Furnaces, both in Scranton, Eckley Miner's Village near Weatherly and the Museum of Anthracite Mining, overlooking the community of Ashland. Plus, there are a few museum exhibits also located at the companion Lackawanna Coal Mine Tour. Okay. So the Lackawanna Coal Mine Tour is where Michael wanted to take the office as a reward in health care in the mine shaft. So this is connected. Yes. So hopefully I said all those names correctly,
1971年由賓夕法尼亞歷史和博物館委員會創建的無煙煤博物館群的一部分，但是女士，這裡有三個。有三個博物館和一個歷史遺址分佈在他們的社區中。珍娜，也許我們可以把這個列入我們的旅遊目的地清單。好的。賓夕法尼亞無煙煤遺產博物館和斯克蘭頓鐵爐，都在斯克蘭頓；韋瑟利附近的埃克利礦工村；以及俯瞰阿什蘭社區的無煙煤採礦博物館。另外，在配套的拉克瓦納煤礦之旅中也有一些博物館展品。好吧。所以拉克瓦納煤礦之旅就是邁克爾在醫療保健那一集中想帶辦公室員工去的地方，作為礦井里的獎勵。所以這是有聯繫的。是的。希望我把所有這些名字都讀對了，
but try saying Lackawanna Coal Mine Tour 10 times fast. I'm going to do it tonight. This is apparently one of Dwight and Angela's favorite places to go, and they went on their first date. That is some very sweet backstory into this couple. Now we have a scene where Michael and Holly are trying to kill time before their dinner reservation. So they're playing crazy aides, so cute. But as they get ready to leave and they're walking out, Holly says she forgot her keys. They need to go back in. But then she says she didn't forget her keys. Not only that, when they go back in, she turns around and locks the door and gives a look to camera. Mm-hmm. She's ready to get it on. She wants to make out in the stairway. Yeah. She's worried we can hear them, though. Yeah, but Michael says don't worry,
但試着快速把「拉克瓦納煤礦之旅」說十遍。我今晚就要試試。這顯然是德懷特和安吉拉最喜歡去的地方之一，而且他們第一次約會就是去那裡。這對這對情侶來說是非常甜蜜的背景故事。現在我們看到一個場景：邁克爾和霍莉在晚宴預訂時間之前試圖打發時間。所以他們在玩「瘋狂疊疊樂」，太可愛了。但當他們準備離開並往外走時，霍莉說她忘帶鑰匙了。他們需要回去。但隨後她說她沒有忘帶鑰匙。不僅如此，當他們返回時，她轉過身把門鎖上，並朝着鏡頭看了一眼。嗯哼。她準備好親熱了。她想在樓梯間擁吻。是的。不過她擔心我們能聽到他們的聲音。是的，但邁克爾說別擔心，
just turn this dial all the way this way, and you'll turn everything off. And now they're just so loud. He's done it the wrong way. It's really pretty amazing. The following morning, people are arriving to work. Michael and Holly are glowing. Mm-hmm. But there's police outside the building. There has been a burglary. Yeah. Stuff has been stolen. Yeah. We had a fan question. Okay. From Lackland A. When Michael and Holly come into the office in the morning, we saw a police car, but we never see any police officers. Was this a continuity error? No. There were police officers, but they're in the deleted scenes. That's right. And there's a really funny scene between Dwight and a police officer in the script. It was really simple. Dwight is asking the police officer,
只要把這個旋鈕一直轉到這邊，你就能把所有的東西都關掉。現在他們聲音太大了。他弄反了方向。這真的很神奇。第二天早上，人們陸續來上班。邁克爾和霍莉滿面春風。嗯哼。但大樓外面有警察。發生了一起入職盜竊案。是的。東西被偷了。是的。我們收到了一個粉絲提問。好的。來自拉克蘭·A。當邁克爾和霍莉早上走進辦公室時，我們看到了警車，但我們從未看到任何警察。這是一個連續性錯誤嗎？不。其實有警察，但他們在刪減片段里。沒錯。劇本里德懷特和一個警察之間有一場非常有趣的戲。非常簡單。德懷特問那個警察：
do you need any crime scene tape? And the police officer is like, you have crime scene tape? And Dwight looks at him like, duh, do you need it? Yeah, exactly. So we did have police officers, but they got cut out. They are in the deleted scenes. That little scene is there. And it's very funny. Well, there has been quite a robbery. A lot was taken. Well, I think we should take a break. And when we come back, let's figure out what was taken. Who did it? What's happening? What is happening? We are back. There's been a burglary at the office. Angela, what was stolen? Tell us, what are we missing? How'd you say burglary? Burglary. Burglary? Burglary? It's a weird word, right? What did I say? I don't know. Burglary? Or did I say burglary? It sounded like you were
你需要任何犯罪現場膠帶嗎？然後警察說：你有犯罪現場膠帶？德懷特看着他，就像看傻子一樣：廢話，你需要嗎？是的，沒錯。所以我們確實有警察，但他們被剪掉了。他們在刪減片段里。那小段戲確實拍了。而且非常搞笑。好吧，確實發生了一場相當大的搶劫。很多東西被偷了。好吧，我想我們應該休息一下。當我們回來時，讓我們弄清楚被偷了什麼。誰幹的？發生了什麼事？到底發生了什麼？我們回來了。辦公室發生了一起入職盜竊案。安吉拉，什麼被偷了？告訴我們，我們少了什麼？你剛才怎麼說的？Burglary（入職盜竊）。Burglary？Burglary？Burglary？這是一個奇怪的詞，對吧？我剛才說了什麼？我不知道。Burglary？還是我說的burglary？聽起來你好像在說
like burglary. I don't know. I don't know. You know what? It is a weird word, burglary. Burglary. Burglary. It sounds like gibberish, like, oh my God, what happened to your house? I had a burglary. Yeah. It's like a thing you say frantically. And if you read it exactly as it's spelled, it's burglary. I had a burglary. Well, what was stolen in the burglary? Okay. According to Dwight, there were security tapes taken, obviously, to cover their thief's tracks. He also thinks that maybe the robbers were vintage HP computer collectors, so I'm guessing a few of the computers are gone. A lot of blank checks. Angela is calling in to the bank to cancel them, Oscar's laptop, Kevin's surge protector, and in deleted scenes, we find out Stanley had
burglary。我不知道。我不知道。你知道嗎？這確實是一個奇怪的詞，burglary。Burglary。Burglary。聽起來像胡言亂語，就像，哦，天哪，你家發生了什麼事？我經歷了一場burglary。是的。這就像一個你驚慌失措時會說的詞。如果你按照它的拼寫來讀，它就是burglary。我遭遇了一場burglary。好吧，在這次入職盜竊中什麼被偷了？好吧。根據德懷特的說法，安全帶被拿走了，很明顯是為了掩蓋小偷的行蹤。他也覺得也許強盜是老式惠普電腦的收藏家，所以我猜有幾台電腦不見了。很多空白支票。安吉拉正打電話給銀行取消它們，奧斯卡的筆記本電腦，凱文的電湧保護器，在刪減片段中，我們發現斯坦利有
a delicious bottle of cream sherry that he was saving to drink on his last day at Dunder Mifflin, so now he's going to have to replace that. Now, Angela, correct me if I'm wrong, but Oscar has this line where he says, I have to get my laptop back. Oh no, lady, I have way hold up. Oh my God, I'm flipping pages. The line she's talking about is going to happen at eight minutes, seven seconds. Now, didn't you guys think he sounded like Jimmy Stewart? Okay, there is a blooper. Oscar says, I don't want to talk. I want my laptop back. And for whatever reason, when we were filming this, it was after lunch, and Oscar had to walk out to like the main bullpen and he had to say, I don't want to talk, I want my laptop back. He couldn't get the line out. And when he finally
一瓶美味的奶油雪利酒，他一直留着準備在鄧德米夫林的最後一天喝，所以現在他不得不換一瓶新的了。現在，安吉拉，如果我沒記錯的話，奧斯卡有一句台詞，他說：我得把我的筆記本電腦拿回來。哦，不，女士，我得等等。哦，天哪，我在翻頁。她說的那句台詞將會在八分七秒時出現。現在，你們不覺得他聽起來像詹姆斯·斯圖爾特嗎？好吧，這裡有一個失誤鏡頭。奧斯卡說：我不想說話。我想要回我的筆記本電腦。不管出於什麼原因，當我們拍攝這場戲時，那是午飯後，奧斯卡不得不走到主辦公區，然後他不得不說：我不想說話，我想要回我的筆記本電腦。他怎麼也說不出這句台詞。當他終於
got the line out, he went like this, I don't want to talk, I want my laptop back. Yeah. And I said in the moment in character, I said, what are you, Jimmy Stewart? And the place lost it. We all lost it because he was like, I want my laptop back. But then if I remember correctly, once he'd done it, he couldn't get rid of it. He couldn't get rid of it. And then everybody jumped on it. So then Rain and John and everyone started going, I want my laptop back. Okay, so I was not there when you filmed the scene. But when I came back, you guys saying, I want my laptop back. That went on for years. Years. That was a bit. And I was like, what is it? What happened? And Oscar was like, F you guys. But he was just like, he got tongue tied after
把這句台詞說出來時，他是這樣說的：我不想說話，我想要回我的筆記本電腦。是的。我在那一刻以角色的身份說：你以為你是誰，詹姆斯·斯圖爾特？現場直接炸開了鍋。我們全都笑瘋了，因為他當時的樣子就像：我想要回我的筆記本電腦。但如果我沒記錯的話，一旦他這樣做了，他就甩不掉這個梗了。他甩不掉這個梗了。然後每個人都加入了進來。所以雷恩、約思和每個人都開始學着說：我想要回我的筆記本電腦。好吧，所以你們拍這場戲的時候我不在現場。但當我回來時，你們所有人都在說：我想要回我的筆記本電腦。這持續了幾年。幾年。這成了一個保留笑話。我當時就想：這是怎麼回事？發生了什麼？奧斯卡就說：去你們的。但他當時只是……他午飯後舌頭打結了。聽着，我們劇組經常這樣。
lunch. Listen, that happened on our show. Big bullpen scenes after lunch, we would get loopy. You know what lived on forever too? Is when I said, you send us all these filthy emails. John Krasinski said that to me for years. Were they filthy? I want my laptop back. You're filthy emails. You're filthy emails. I want you to know that Kevin is really, really concerned about his surge protector. He's worried about surges. This sent me down a road. I need to know more about power surges. And I am not going to bore you with everything I read. I will give you this one nugget because I didn't know it. I'm telling you, I want a screen grab of your search engine. I know. I'm going to frame it. I know.
午飯後的大辦公區戲份，我們總是會變得神神叨叨的。你知道什麼也永遠流傳下來了嗎？就是當我說：你們給我們發了所有這些色情電子郵件。約翰·卡拉辛斯基連續好幾年都對我這麼說。它們很色情嗎？我想要回我的筆記本電腦。你發的色情電子郵件。你發的色情電子郵件。我想讓你們知道，凱文真的、真的很擔心他的電湧保護器。他擔心電壓浪涌。這讓我陷入了一次深入的研究。我需要了解更多關於電湧的知識。我不會用我讀到的所有內容來煩你們。我會告訴你們這一個乾貨，因為我以前真的不知道。我告訴你，我很想截屏你的搜尋引擎。我知道。我要把它錶框起來。我知道。
I thought power surges were just like giant things that happened, like some lightning strikes or something. And I need a surge protector because of like, you know, big moments. Can't they happen just because you have too much stuff plugged in? Like I blow dried my hair one time and it blew out the outlet. Yeah, there's something called mini surges. And that happens every time your air conditioner kicks on, like you get a mini surge and it can slowly damage your appliances over time because your house can get like a buildup of mini surges. So Kevin is right. You really need to surge protect your house. I also found out you can get a whole house surge suppressor. They connect to your fuse box. I don't even know if I have one. I need to find
我以前以為電湧只是那種偶爾發生的巨型事件，比如某處遭到閃電擊中之類的。我需要一個電湧保護器是因為，你知道的，那些重大時刻。難道它們不是因為你插了太多東西才發生的嗎？就像我有一次用吹風機吹頭髮，結果把插座都給吹短路了。是的，有一種東西叫微型電湧。每當你的空調啟動時，這種情況就會發生，比如你會遭遇一次微型電湧，它會隨時間慢慢損壞你的電器，因為你的家裡可能會累積微型電湧。所以凱文是對的。你真的需要給你的房子安裝電湧保護器。我還發現你可以買一個全屋電湧抑制器。它們連接到你的保險絲盒。我甚至都不知道我家里有沒有這東西。我得去找找
out because I got so worried about surges after my search. I feel like you would know if you had a surge suppressor. I mean, we probably do. That's Lee's department. He handles that stuff. Right. You know, we divide things up more traditionally in that way. If it's electrical or yard oriented, that's on Lee. I should ask him. I'm the yard person at my house. I love the yard. I love being outside. I love to garden. I know our sprinkler system. I said it. I'm on station fours looking wonky. Let's fix that. Yeah, that's on Lee. I've got my allergies. I'm inside. You're inside person. Well, listen, Michael and Holly are starting to connect the dots. They're like, oh, no. Oh, no. Wait, did we lock? Did you lock it? I didn't lock it. Oh, no. This is
因为我在搜索之后非常担心遭遇电涌。我觉得如果有电涌保护器，你应该会知道。我是说，我们可能有一个。那是李的部门。他负责那些。没错。你知道，我们在那方面传统分工更明确。如果是电路或院子方面的事情，那是李负责的。我应该问问他。我是我家管院子的人。我喜欢院子。我喜欢待在外面。我喜欢园艺。我懂我们的喷水系统。我说了。我觉得四号工位看起来怪怪的。我们修一下吧。对，那是李负责的。我有过敏症。我在室内。你是室内派。好吧，听着，迈克尔和霍莉开始把线索串联起来了。他们觉得，哦，不。哦，不。等等，我们锁门了吗？你锁了吗？我没锁。哦，不。这是
their fault. So much for sex without consequences. Yes. That is Michael's talking head. But Jenna, there was an alt in the script that made me laugh so hard. There was one extra line. And this was the other version of this talking head. So much for sex without consequences. Well, I guess with great sex comes great responsibility. Yes. And that one was deleted. That is such a good line. I know. During all of this mayhem, Jim is listening to a message from Pam. It's a butt dial message. It goes on and on. Clearly she went out last night. Sounds like she had another volcano. Yeah. She's out partying with her art school pals. They're whipping it up, whipping it, whooping it, whooping it up. I think they're whooping it up. Yeah. And Jim is just kind of
他们的错。无后果的性爱到此为止。没错。那是迈克尔的独白。但是珍娜，剧本里有一个备选版本让我笑得前仰后合。多了一句台词。这是这个独白的另一个版本。无后果的性爱到此为止。好吧，我想，伟大的性爱伴随着伟大的责任。是的。而那一版被删掉了。这台词写得真好。我知道。在一片混乱中，吉姆正在听彭姆的留言。那是一个误触拨号的留言。它没完没了。很显然她昨听晚出去了。听起来她又经历了一次“火山爆发”。是的。她和艺术学校的伙伴们在外面狂欢。他们在胡闹，胡闹，狂欢，狂欢。我觉得他们在狂欢。是的。吉姆当时就觉得
like future mother of my children right there. Yep. Which is what Lee said when I got home from my bachelorette party that you hosted, Angela. And I was throwing up in the bushes. He said, you're the future mother of my children. I couldn't be prouder of you. Angela says she's never felt safe here. And he says she's safe with him, because he's a very good screamer. That made me laugh so hard. Dwight has grabbed Phyllis. They're in the elevator. He had to talk to her right away. He says he knows that Angela loves him. She's practically told him so. Well, Phyllis says then you need to offer her an ultimatum. That's what Bob did to Phyllis. Yeah. He said she had to stop talking to her sister so much. Oh, Phyllis. I know.
这不就是我未来的孩子他妈嘛。没错。这正是我结束你主持的单身派对回家时，李对我说的话，安吉拉。当时我正在灌木丛旁呕吐。他说，你是我未来孩子的母亲。我为你感到无比骄傲。安吉拉说她从来没在这里感到安全过。而他说她在他身边很安全，因为他非常擅长尖叫。这把我笑得不行。德怀特抓住了菲利斯。他们在电梯里。他必须马上跟她谈谈。他说他知道安吉拉爱他。她几乎已经亲口告诉他了。好吧，菲利斯说那你得给她下最后通牒。鲍勃就是这么对菲利斯的。对。他说她必须少跟她姐姐说话。哦，菲利斯。我知道。
Well, Jen Salata shared that shooting this elevator scene was crazy, because we do not actually have a working elevator. Remember, we've shared before that if we went into the elevator, we would shoot part of the scene, and then we would have to relocate to the other building where the bottom of the elevator is. Right. And the lobby. And there are always guys sort of standing on either side off-camera with ropes, and they would pull the doors open and they would shut the doors. That is a pulley system door, you guys. There was nothing electric about that elevator. It is super fakey-fake, old-timey, just pulleys and people and ropes making this box of wood turn into an elevator. Well, she said that they didn't want to relocate. So they did this crazy thing,
好吧，珍·萨拉塔分享说，拍摄这场电梯戏简直太疯狂了，因为我们实际上并没有一个能用的电梯。还记得我们之前分享过，如果我们走进电梯，我们会拍一部分戏，然后我们就得转场到另一栋建筑，那里有电梯井底部。没错。还有大厅。而且总有几个工作人员拿着绳子站在镜头外的两侧，他们会把门拉开，然后把门关上。各位，那是滑轮系统开合的门。那个电梯一点电动的成分都没有。超级假，老派，就是靠滑轮、人和绳子把这个木头箱子变成一部电梯。好吧，她说他们不想转场。所以他们做了一件疯狂的事，
which is so amazing. What they did was while Phyllis and Dwight are inside the elevator doing the scene, a bunch of crew members came out and redressed the front part hallway of the elevator. So they came in. They put carpeting over the tile and they added a potted plant so that when the doors opened again and Phyllis stepped out, it would look like a new floor. They were in the correct place. And Jen said, if you look closely, when Phyllis gets out of the elevator, the plant is still moving because they had to just like slap that plant down really quickly and book it out of there. That to me feels like theater. That's what it's like when you do a play. It's like- Yes! You have three seconds to reset dress the area while you're putting a blouse on
这太惊人了。他们做的是，当菲利斯和德怀特在电梯里拍戏时，一堆剧组人员出来重新布置了电梯前方的走廊。所以他们进来了。他们在瓷砖上铺了地毯，还加了一盆盆栽，这样当门再次打开，菲利斯迈步走出来时，看起来就像是一个新的楼层。他们就在正确的位置上。珍说，如果你仔细看，当菲利斯走下电梯时，那盆植物还在动，因为他们必须非常快地把植物往那一扔，然后赶紧撤出来。对我来说，这感觉就像是剧院。这就像你在演一出话剧。就像——没错！你有三秒钟的时间在换上另一件衬衫的同时重置和布置场地，然后一堆人把沙发推上舞台，接着你走出去，灯光亮起。没错！完全是这样！而且你知道，这场戏他们必须拍好多次。所以那天在工作时，有这样一群人一直在铺地毯、收地毯，放植物、拿植物，一遍又一遍。
over the other blouse and then a bunch of guys are sliding a sofa onto the stage and then you walk out and the lights come up. Yes! Totally! And you know, they had to do multiple takes of this. So that day at work, there were these people who just like threw down carpeting and picked up carpeting and threw down a plant and picked up a plant over and over again. And grabbed the ropes and pulled the elevator, jumped the elevator. Yes! Aww. Movie magic. Sometimes it's just practical. Yep. Meanwhile, there is a lot of hubbub about the burglary. Holly says her door is open if anyone wants to talk. Creed has his amazing talking head. It's so good. He says nobody steals from him and gets away with it. You know the last person who did that? They disappeared and his name was Creed
还要抓住绳子拉电梯，让电梯上下。没错。噢。电影的魔术。有时它就是这么实用。没错。与此同时，关于入室盗窃有很多议论。霍莉说她的门随时敞开着，如果有人想聊聊的话。克里德有一段精彩绝伦的独白。太棒了。他说没有人能从他这里偷东西还能逃脱惩罚。你知道上一个这么做的人是谁吗？他失踪了，他的名字叫克里德
Bratton. My favorite part, though, is he goes, his name, Creed Bratton. He like whispers his own name. Clearly, he has killed Creed Bratton and taken his identity. What's happening? That's what you're led to believe. Well, Michael's going to make everything right. He's going to call a conference room meeting, and he has an idea. He's going to have a charity auction. Right. It's going to be called crime aid, and it's like farm aid, but instead of farms fighting aides, it's going to be us fighting our own poverty. No one likes the idea. But Phyllis. Phyllis is like, yeah, we did this in my sorority. We can auction off fun things like tennis lessons. We had a few people write in, they were wondering why do we have to have a charity auction? Like, wouldn't the insurance
布拉顿。不过我最喜欢的部分是他说，他的名字叫克里德·布拉顿。他竟然小声念出了自己的名字。很明显，他已经杀了克里德·布拉顿并顶替了他的身份。到底怎么回事？这就是你想让人相信的。好吧，迈克尔要让一切重回正轨。他要召开一个会议室会议，他有个主意。他要举办一个慈善拍卖会。没错。它将被称为“犯罪援助”（Crime Aid），就像“农场援助”（Farm Aid）一样，但不是农场对抗援助，而是我们对抗我们自己的贫穷。没人喜欢这个主意。除了菲利斯。菲利斯说，好吧，我们在我的姐妹会里做过这个。我们可以拍卖有趣的东西，比如网球课。有几个人写信来，他们想知道为什么我们非得办一个慈善拍卖会？难道保险
cover the cost of the missing items? I think this is a good question. Charlie Grandy, our writer, said that there was a scene that got cut for time in which Michael would have explained that their insurance has a $5,000 deductible for personal items. They lost less than $5,000 worth of stuff, so none of that was covered. That's true. It's a scene between Michael and Holly, and Holly explains to Michael that personal items are not covered. And so that is the reason for this big auction. As they're sort of discussing this in the conference room, Angela's like, who would come to this? Michael's like, I don't know. Pedestrians, looky lose. That was my favorite. Looky lose. Looky lose. Maybe Bruce Springsteen fans. Everyone's like, what? Yeah, Michael says
不应该承担失窃物品的费用吗？我觉得这是一个好问题。我们的编剧查理·格兰迪说，有一场戏因为时间关系被剪掉了，迈克尔在其中会解释说，他们的保险对个人物品有5000美元的免赔额。他们丢失的东西价值不到5000万美元（应为5000美元），所以这些都不在理赔范围内。确实如此。这是迈克尔和霍莉之间的一场戏，霍莉向迈克尔解释说个人物品是不在理赔范围内的。所以这就是举办这场盛大拍卖会的原因。正当他们在会议室讨论时，安吉拉说，谁会来这儿？迈克尔说，我不知道。路人、看热闹的。我最喜欢这个了。看热闹的。看热闹的。也许是布鲁斯·斯普林斯廷的粉丝。大家都说，什么？对，迈克尔说
he has scored Springsteen tickets, and he's going to auction them off. Jenna, I have a Springsteen story. What is it? You guys know I interned on Conan O'Brien, right? Yeah. In my early 20s. So I was Max Weinberg's intern. Max was the band leader for the Conan O'Brien show, but boss fans know that he was also the drummer for Bruce Springsteen in the E Street Band. So here I am, Jenna. I'm this young intern. Max comes out of his office and says, hey, Bruce Springsteen is going to be calling me. I'm going to be down in the studio. I'm going to need you to forward his call to me. And I was like, what? What? And I was like cold sweat. He was like, yeah, he should call, you know, while I'm down there. I was like, okay. I sat by that phone. I had to pee. I was like,
他弄到了斯普林斯廷的门票，他要把它们拿出来拍卖。珍娜，我有一个关于斯普林斯廷的故事。是什么？你们知道我曾在柯南·奥布莱恩的节目实习过，对吧？是的。在我二十岁出头的时候。所以我是马克斯·温伯格的实习生。马克斯是柯南·奥布莱恩节目的乐队领队，但老牌粉丝都知道，他也是布鲁斯·斯普林斯廷在E街乐队的鼓手。所以现在我在这里，珍娜。我是一个年轻的实习生。马克斯从办公室走出来说，嘿，布鲁斯·斯普林斯廷一会儿要打电话给我。我要去录音室。我需要你帮我把他的电话转接给我。当时我就想，什么？什么？然后我吓出一身冷汗。他说，对，他应该会打电话，你知道的，等我下去之后。我说，好吧。我坐在那个电话旁边。我想上厕所。我就想，
I can't go pee. I can't go pee. Bruce Springsteen is calling. I know. And then I was like, wait, I don't know how to forward. No one showed me that. I sat there sweating it. And then Max comes back up and I was like, Bruce never called. I sat here the whole time. Jenna, I almost peed my pants. He never called. He was like, oh, well, he might call later today, sometime today. I was like, sometime today. I thought I like couldn't leave my phone right then and there. And then one time someone dropped off a package from Bruce for Max. And there was a little card on the outside and it just said dash B, like to Max dash B. I was like, Oh my God, I am holding a card that Bruce Springsteen wrote on that B is him. That's pretty cool. Wait, but you never got to hear his voice on the phone.
我不能去上厕所。我不能去上厕所。布鲁斯·斯普林斯廷要打电话来。我知道。然后我想，等等，我不知道怎么转接。没人教过我这个。我坐在那里直冒冷汗。然后马克斯上来了，我说，布鲁斯没打电话。我一直坐在这儿。珍娜，我差点尿裤子。他根本没打电话。他说，哦，好吧，他可能今天晚些时候打，今天某个时候。我说，今天某个时候？我当时觉得我简直不能离开我的电话半步。然后有一次，有人送来了一个布鲁斯给马克斯的包裹。外面有一张小卡片，上面只写着“破折号B”，就像“给马克斯，——B”。当时我就想，天哪，我手里拿着一张布鲁斯·斯普林斯廷亲笔写的卡片，那个B就是他。这太酷了。等等，但你从来没有在电话里听到过他的声音。
Jenna, this is not the best story. I just want you to know I waited for a call from him. I almost got to talk to him. It didn't happen. But I did get to hold a piece of paper he wrote on. Well, I got to see Bruce Springsteen live on Broadway when he did his Broadway show and it was fantastic. Did you talk to him? No. Oh, and I've also never held a card that says dash B. So I think you're closer. I'm closer to meeting the boss. You are. Dwight is going to take Phyllis's advice. He is going to give Angela an ultimatum. She has until 6.14 p.m. to break up with Andy. Apologize and start dating Dwight. Or you don't get any of this. We could not get through it. It's in the bloopers. We both started laughing. It was so ridiculous. This is a fantastic ultimatum though.
珍娜，这并不是最棒的故事。我只是想让你知道，我等过他的电话。我差一点就能和他说话了。虽然没能实现。但我确实拿到了一张他亲笔写过字的纸。好吧，我有幸在百老汇现场看过布鲁斯·斯普林斯廷的演出，当时他演了百老汇秀，棒极了。你跟他说话了吗？没有。哦，而且我也没拿过写着“——B”的卡片。所以我觉得你离他更近。我离“老板”（The Boss）更近了。你是的。德怀特决定听从菲利斯的建议。他要给安吉拉下最后通牒。她有直到下午6点14分的时间跟安迪分手。道歉并开始和德怀特约会。否则你什么也得不到。我们根本没办法顺利演完。这在失误花絮里。我们两个都笑场了。太荒谬了。不过这真是一个绝妙的最后通牒。
I know. Angela, is it time for the auction? It is time for a crime reduces and a sense makes everyone angry. I declare. Yes. Michael says there may not be a Wikipedia entry for Office Robbery Statistics. Yet its victims are standing strong together. So there is still no Wikipedia page for Office Robbery Statistics. And I'll tell you why because you looked it up. After the show aired, fans kept trying to make a Wikipedia page for Office Robbery Statistics. And Wikipedia had to keep taking it down. So now if you type in Office Robbery Statistics, Wikipedia will direct you to the episode crime aid. And there is a note that says, Office Robbery Statistics was redirected to this page to prevent further attempted creations. Oh my gosh. You guys are
我知道。安吉拉，拍卖会时间到了吗？是时候让犯罪减少、让理智让每个人生气的时刻了。我宣布。是的。迈克尔说，维基百科上可能还没有关于“办公室抢劫统计数据”的词条。但它的受害者们正并肩挺立。所以维基百科上仍然没有“办公室抢劫统计数据”这个页面。我来告诉你为什么，因为你查过了。节目播出后，粉丝们一直试图为“办公室抢劫统计数据”创建一个维基百科页面。而维基百科不得不一次次把它删掉。所以现在如果你输入“办公室抢劫统计数据”，维基百科会把你引导到“犯罪援助”那一集。并且上面有一条注释写着：“办公室抢劫统计数据”已被重定向到此页面，以防止再次尝试创建。哦，天哪。你们太
persistent. Also, we had a fan question from Brandon L who wanted to know who wrote the acronym Crime Aid for the show. Guys, this was all Charlie Grandy. He said he spent three hours writing various combinations and he settled on this one. Oh, I love that it took him three hours. That just feeds my soul because how many times do I have you and I sat down to write something and I'm like, well, I spent half an hour on two words. Yes. Combinations. It's time for the auction to start. We've got good stuff. We do. I have a list of what all was auctioned off. Ready? Yes. We have a yoga lesson from Holly sold to Michael for $300 because no one else would bid on it. Beers with the warehouse guys from Darryl sold to Jim for $5. But you have to go right now.
执着了。另外，我们收到了来自布兰登·L的一位粉丝提问，他想知道是谁为节目创作了“Crime Aid”（犯罪援助）这个首字母缩略词。大家，这全是查理·格兰迪想出来的。他说他花了三个小时写了各种组合，最后敲定了这个。哦，我太喜欢他花了三个小时这事了。这简直滋养了我的心灵，因为我和你坐下来写东西时，有多少次我也是这样，心想，好吧，我在两个词上花了半个小时。没错。各种组合。拍卖会要开始了好东西挺多。确实。我有一份拍卖物品清单。准备好了吗？好的。我们有霍莉提供的瑜伽课，以300美元卖给了迈克尔，因为其他人都不出价。达里尔提供的和仓库小伙子们一起喝啤酒的机会，以5美元卖给了吉姆。但你得马上就去。
It's beers right now with the warehouse guys. Yes. And there was a scripted Jim talking head that didn't make it in that would explain why he felt like he could leave right away. Jim says, Pam loves Bruce Springsteen. I love Bruce Springsteen and I'm really excited about these tickets. My one reservation is that Bruce Springsteen is not currently touring. So I'm leaving. All right. The next thing auctioned off was a Creed all inclusive. Creed, he's auctioning off himself. No bids. Kevin will do your taxes federal and state. No bids. Hank sings the blues and he's auctioning off his CDs. No bids that we see anyway. David Wallace coming in strong, auctioning off a weekend at his home on Martha's Vineyard.
现在就要去和仓库小伙子们喝啤酒。对。剧本里原本有一段吉姆的独白没能播出来，这段独白本可以解释为什么他觉得自己可以马上离开。吉姆说，彭姆喜欢布鲁斯·斯普林斯廷。我喜欢布鲁斯·斯普林斯廷，我对这些门票感到非常兴奋。我唯一的顾虑是布鲁斯·斯普林斯廷目前并没有在巡演。所以我这就走。好。接下来拍卖的是克里德全包套餐。克里德，他在拍卖他自己。无人出价。凯文帮你报税，联邦和州税。无人出价。汉克唱蓝调，他正在拍卖他的CD。反正我们没看到有人出价。大卫·华尔斯强势登场，拍卖他在玛莎葡萄园岛家中的周末度假。
Multiple bids. We don't know where it landed. Phyllis auctions off a hug. Bob wins that one for $1,000. And in deleted scenes, Kelly auctions off dance lessons. And also Meredith mumbles something. No one can tell what she's saying. Oscar says, fine, I bid a dollar. And then she tosses him a brand new iPhone. That's so funny. Everyone's like, what? That's all the items auctioned. According to the bar graph thingy, it looks like they raised $1,803. I have a lot of fan questions and catches based on everything you said. Angela, starting with Audrey E. During the auction, there's a giant goal thermometer, but the goal isn't at the top of the thermometer. It's like they're only trying
多次出价。我们不知道最后花落谁家。菲利斯拍卖一个拥抱。鲍勃以1000美元赢得了那个。在被删减的片段中，凯利拍卖舞蹈课。还有梅雷迪思嘟囔了一些话。没人听清她在说什么。奥斯卡说，好吧，我出一美元。然后她扔给他一部全新的iPhone。太搞笑了。大家都心想，什么？这就是所有拍卖的物品。根据那个条形图来看，他们似乎筹集了1803美元。根据你们所说的一切，我有很多粉丝提问和发现。安吉拉，从奥黛丽·E开始。拍卖期间，有一个巨大的目标温度计，但目标不在温度计的最顶端。就像他们只想
to fill it partway up. That's a really funny detail. Yes. This detail was an intentional joke that was written into the script. In the script, it says the amount raised thermometer goes up to $1 million, even though the goal is $3,400, which should be written a little over a foot from the bottom. That was a script note. Yeah. So yes, very funny little detail. And did you notice whenever Michael was being the auctioneer, if bid started going high, he would throw in a million dollars. He'd be like, $100, $200, $1 million. Okay, $400. We had a fan catch from many people, Erica P., Rob O., Katie D., and Ashley S., when Jim leaves to go to the bar with Darryl, Michael auctions off Creed. But if you look, Jim is seated behind Creed. Oh,
把它填满一部分。这是一个非常有趣的细节。是的。这个细节是剧本里写好的一个刻意笑话。剧本里写着，筹集金额的温度计一直上升到100万美元，尽管目标是3400美元，这个数字应该写在离底部一英尺多一点的地方。那是剧本里的备注。是的，所以这是一个非常有趣的搞笑小细节。大家有没有注意到，每当迈克尔担任拍卖师时，如果出价开始走高，他就会抛出100万美元。他会说，100美元，200美元，100万美元。好吧，400美元。我们收到了许多人的粉丝发现，埃里卡·P、罗布·O、凯蒂·D和阿什利·S发现，当吉姆离开去和达里尔去酒吧时，迈克尔正在拍卖克里德。但如果你仔细看，吉姆正坐在克里德身后。哦，
oh, good catch. Jim should not be there, but clearly we moved those scenes around. Yep. Also, fan question from Catherine D., Lexie B., and Maddie L., is Hank really a blues musician? No. So not only is Hugh Dane, who plays Hank, not a blues musician, he had never played the guitar before that day. And this bit about Hank being a blues musician was a holdover from an earlier draft of the script. Jen Salata told me it didn't even make it in the shooting draft, but there was a whole storyline where Oscar and Kevin were going to try to solve the crime of who broke into the office. And they decide that it must be an inside job because the door wasn't broken. So they're interviewing everyone. They interview Hank and they say, Hank,
哦，好眼力。吉姆不应该在那儿的，但很显然我们把那些场景调换了顺序。没错。还有来自凯瑟琳·D、莱克西·B和麦迪·L的粉丝提问，汉克真的是个蓝调音乐家吗？不是。所以不仅饰演汉克的休·丹恩不是蓝调音乐家，他在那之前甚至从未弹过吉姆（应为吉姆，指吉他，这里原意是弹吉他）。而关于汉克是蓝调音乐家的这个梗，是剧本早期草稿中保留下来的。珍·萨拉塔告诉我，它甚至没有进入拍摄剧本，但原本有一个完整的剧情线，奥斯卡和凯文要试图解开是谁闯入办公室的案件。他们断定这一定是内部作案，因为门没有被破坏。所以他们在采访每个人。他们采访了汉克，他们说，汉克，
do you have a record? And Hank says, I do have a record, but it's a blues record, not a criminal record. So Jen always loved that joke that Hank said, I have a record, I have a blues record. So she said, I want Hank to auction off his blues record at this auction. But it was a super last minute pitch. Jen told me they only had a couple hours to make the prop CD, which is why if you notice, Hank is wearing the same outfit in the CD that he's wearing in the episode. Well, and it also said in the script that Hank plays very poorly. And we're all having to sit there and listen. Angela, because of this auction, I became inspired to find out what are some of the world's best selling auction items. Like what you've seen in the news,
你有案底吗？汉克说，我确实有案底（record也有唱片的意思），但我是有蓝调唱片，没有犯罪记录。所以珍一直很喜欢汉克说的这个笑话，汉克说，我有一张唱片，我有一张蓝调唱片。所以她说，我想让汉克在这场拍卖会上拍卖他的蓝调唱片。但这真的是临时起意的点子。珍告诉我，他们只有几个小时的时间来制作道具CD，这就是为什么如果你注意看，汉克在CD封面上穿的衣服和他在这集里穿的一模一样。而且剧本里还写着汉克弹得非常糟糕。我们所有人都得坐在那儿听。安吉拉，因为这场拍卖，我深受启发，想要去了解一下世界上最畅销的拍卖品有哪些。就像你在新闻里看到的，
like Christie's auctioned off a Picasso or something like that. Yes. Okay. Yes. I have a list. Of the highest paid items ever at an auction? Yes. Oh. In certain categories. Oh. For example, the world's most expensive work of art sold at auction was a 500-year-old painting of Jesus Christ believed to have been painted by Leonardo da Vinci. Oh, I was going to say da Vinci's on this list. I really was. Okay, go. The painting is known as Salvatore Mundi, which means savior of the world. And it sold at Christie's auction in 2017 for $450 million. Dang. Who bought it? I don't know. Oh my God. I wouldn't want you to know that I have that. I mean, that feels like a security risk. Right. It's got to be anonymous. I don't know if it is or not, but it didn't say.
比如佳士得拍卖了一幅毕加索的作品之类的。是的。好的。是的。我有一份清单。关于拍卖史上拍出最高价的物品？是的。哦。在某些类别中。哦。例如，拍卖会上售出的世界上最昂贵的艺术品是一幅有500年历史的耶稣基督画作，据信是达芬奇画的。哦，我正要说达芬奇就在这个名单上。我真的是这么想的。好吧，请继续。这幅画被称为《救世主》（Salvatore Mundi），意思是世界的拯救者。它在2017年的佳士得拍卖会上以4.5亿美元的价格售出。天哪。谁买的？我不知道。哦，天哪。我可不想让别人知道我有这个。我是说，这感觉像是一个安全隐患。对。一定得是匿名的。我不知道是不是，但上面没说。
The record for the most expensive work of art by a living artist goes to Jeff Koons, his rabbit sculpture, which sold for $91.1 million in May of 2019. Wow. Jeff Koons actually has two of the top five items that were most expensive for a living artist. Also, his dog sculpture is like balloon dog. Wow. The most expensive dress ever sold at an auction. Oh, can I guess? Yes. Was it either Audrey Hepburn or like Princess Diana? It's Marilyn Monroe. Oh, Marilyn Monroe. Why did I say Marilyn Monroe? Her happy birthday, Mr. President gown. Oh, yes. It sold for $4.8 million in 2016. The most expensive wrist watch ever auctioned. I mean, I found this fascinating because I was like, really? A watch sold for $31 million. I don't get it.
在世艺术家创作的最昂贵的艺术品纪录由杰夫·昆斯保持，他的兔子雕塑在2019年5月以9110万美元的价格售出。哇。杰夫·昆斯实际上占据了在世艺术家最昂贵作品前五名中的两席。还有他的狗狗雕塑，就像气球狗那样。哇。拍卖史上售出的最昂贵的裙子。哦，我能猜一下吗？请。是奥黛丽·赫本的还是戴安娜王妃的？是玛丽莲·梦露的。哦，玛丽莲·梦露。我怎么会说玛丽莲·梦露呢？她唱“生日快乐，总统先生”时穿的那件礼服。哦，是的。它在2016年以480万美元的价格售出。拍卖史上售出的最昂贵的手表。我是说，我觉得这太迷人了，因为当时我想，真的吗？一块手表能卖到3100万美元？我不理解。
It's called a Patek Philippe watch. It was in the Grand Master Chime model. Now, does it make more sense, Angela? It was a Grand Master Chime. Somewhere there's someone fancy and their ears are bleeding because they're like, ladies, you have no idea what you're talking about. Yeah. We need to pay $31 million for the Grand Master Chime. I hid this watch up my ass. Oh boy, that watch. I'd love to know how much that watch could go for an auction. But this shattered the record. The previous record was a Rolex that was once owned by Paul Newman and it had sold for 17.7. I don't want to tell people that they're spending their money wrong, but I don't know. Do you want to know the most expensive diamonds? I mean, does Elizabeth have one? No, sorry. Elizabeth Taylor
它叫百达翡丽手表。是大师弦音（Grand Master Chime）款式。现在，这听起来合理点了吗，安吉拉？这是一块大师弦音。某个地方有某个有钱人，他们的耳朵正在流血，因为他们心想，女士们，你们根本不知道自己在说什么。是的。我们需要为大师弦音支付3100万美元。我把这块手表藏在我的屁股里。哦天哪，那块手表。我很想知道那块手表在拍卖会上能卖多少钱。但这打破了纪录。之前的纪录是一块曾由保罗·纽曼拥有的劳力士，它曾以1770万美元的价格售出。我不想告诉别人他们的钱花得不对，但我不知道。你们想知道最昂贵的钻石吗？我是说，伊丽莎白（泰勒）有一颗吗？不，抱歉。伊丽莎白·泰勒
did not sell the most expensive diamond. The most expensive blue diamond ever sold in auction history was the Oppenheimer Blue and it sold for $57.9 million. The most expensive diamond diamond was sold for $71.2 million at an auction in Hong Kong and it is a 59.6 carat pink star diamond. Wow. And it was the largest flawless, fancy, vivid pink diamond ever graded by the Gemological Institute of America. What do you do with that? I don't know. It is... What do you do with that? It would stress me out. I don't know what you do with it. I mean, I'm always like, you know, you have one lamp that's nicer than your other lamps and I'm always like to the kids, don't touch that lamp. Guys. You guys stop touching the pink star diamond. Stop it. If you have to
并没有卖出最昂贵的钻石。拍卖史上售出的最昂贵的蓝钻是“奥本海默蓝钻”（The Oppenheimer Blue），售价为5790万美元。最昂贵的钻石在香港的一场拍卖会上以7120万美元的价格售出，这是一颗59.6克拉的粉红之星（Pink Star）钻石。哇。这是美国宝石学院评级过的最大、无瑕的艳彩粉红钻石。你拿它做什么？我不知道。它是……你拿着它能做什么？这会让我压力山大。我不知道你能拿它做什么。我是说，我总是觉得，你知道的，你有一个比其他灯更好看的灯，我总是对孩子们说，别碰那个灯。大家。你们别再碰粉红之星钻石了。停下。如果你非要
play with something, play with the Oppenheimer Blue. Do not throw the Frisbee near that diamond. Damn it. Stop it, guys. That's how my other diamond broke. Exactly. And no, you cannot wear my Grandmaster Chime to school. Finally, I'm going to tell you what I am assuming is the most expensive used tissue. What? That has ever been auctioned. I can't be sure. Who wants a used tissue? Somebody did. Did Elvis blow his nose? Is it an Elvis tissue? No, it belonged to Scarlett Johansson. She sold it for $2,050 on eBay. The story is that she had been on The Tonight Show with Jay Leno in 2008 and she had a cold. She said, Samuel Jackson gave me a cold. And she said, you know what? I'm going to auction off my tissue for charity. And she did. Okay. All right. You
玩点什么，去玩奥本海默蓝钻吧。千万别在那颗钻石附近玩飞盘。该死。住手，伙计们。我的另一颗钻石就是这么碎的。没错。还有，不行，你不准戴我的大师弦音去上学。最后，我要告诉你一件我猜是史上最昂贵的用过的纸巾的东西。什么？曾经被拍卖过的东西。我不敢确定。谁会想要用过的纸巾？还真有人要。猫王擤过鼻涕吗？这是猫王的纸巾吗？不是，它属于斯嘉丽·约翰逊。她在eBay上以2050美元的价格把它卖了。故事是这样的，她在2008年上杰·雷诺的《今夜秀》时感冒了。她说，塞缪尔·杰克逊传染了我感冒。然后她说，你知道吗？我要把我的纸巾拿出来拍卖做慈善。她真的这么做了。好吧。好吧。
know what I learned here? People bid crazy amounts of money on really random things. Yeah. Should we go to the bar? Should we get back to the episode and go to the bar? I guess so. Well, Jim and the warehouse fellows are having a great time at the bar. Jim's going to get another round. Yeah. He heads over to the bar. And who walks in? It's Roy. Roy Anderson. He's like, Albert. And Jim's like, huh? And Roy's like, don't worry. I'm not going to hit you. So Jim and Roy end up having a rather friendly conversation over some beers. They're catching up on life. He's telling Roy about Pam. Yeah. He tells Roy Pam's at art school and also she's engaged to me. And Roy's like, wow, okay. And then they kind of do like a, they don't quite shake hands. It's weird. It's like Roy holds his
你知道我从这学到了什么吗？人们会在非常随机的东西上疯狂出价。是的。我们去酒吧吗？我们该回到剧集里去酒吧了吗？我想是的。好吧，吉姆和仓库的小伙子们在酒吧里玩得很开心。吉姆要去再买一轮酒。是的。他朝吧台走去。谁走进来了？是罗伊。罗伊·安德森。他说，阿尔伯特（Halpert）。吉姆说，啊？罗伊说，别担心。我不会揍你的。所以吉姆和罗伊最后一边喝着啤酒，一边进行了相当友好的对话。他们叙了叙近况。他正在向罗伊讲述彭姆的事。是的。他告诉罗伊彭姆在艺术学校，而且她还跟我订婚了。罗伊说，哇，好吧。然后他们做了一个，他们没有真的握手。感觉很奇怪。就像罗伊把手
hand up over his shoulder and then Jim grabs it. They have some type of bro handshake moment. I loved that. Jim even sort of doubles down and is like, oh yeah, she's having a great time at art school. She was out till like nine in the morning with her friends. And then Roy says, huh, you were a friend. And Jim is like, oh crap. Oh crap. Like it kind of plants the seed of doubt in Jim's brain like it's Pam connecting with other people, the way she connected with me, what's going on at art school. So Jim spirals. And he's like, I'm going to go see her. I'm going to go see her. I'm going to drive to New York. Yeah. I want you guys to know that there were some missing scenes in this Jim and Pam storyline. There were extra scenes because we did get some mail from people where
举过肩膀，然后吉姆抓住了它。他们来了一次某种兄弟式的握手。我太喜欢了。吉姆甚至有点加码地说，哦对，她在艺术学校过得很棒。她跟朋友们在外面一直玩到早上九点左右。然后罗伊说，哦，你还挺大方（原意是“你倒挺放心的/你算什么朋友”）。吉姆就想，哦糟了。哦糟了。这就像是在吉姆脑海中埋下了怀疑的种子，就像彭姆和别人建立联系一样，就像她曾经和我建立联系那样，艺术学校里到底在发生什么。所以吉姆情绪失控了。他心想，我要去见她。我要去见她。我要开车去纽约。是的。我想让你们知道，在这个吉姆和彭姆的故事线中，有一些被漏掉的场景。有一些额外的场景，因为我们确实收到了一些观众的来信，
they were like, wow, this one comment from Roy really made Jim spiral. You know, why was he so insecure about their relationship? Now we know he's going to turn around. He's not actually going to drive to New York. He's going to turn around. But there's a lot more motivating this spiral than just Roy's comment. Yes, there was a whole storyline, you guys, between Jim and Pam that would have started early in the episode and would have built to this moment. Yeah. So earlier, remember Jim was on the phone and he got this voicemail from Pam where she's out with her friends. Well, what's missing is that there was a really cute bit where Jim and Pam are talking on the phone and they are talking about the West Wing. Yes. And Jenna, it's so cute. They share that they watch it together
他们说，哇，罗伊的这句评论真的让吉姆情绪崩溃了。你知道，为什么他对他们的关系这么没有安全感？现在我们知道了，他会调头。他其实不会开车去纽约。他会调头的。但引发这种情绪崩溃的动机，可不仅仅是罗伊的一句话。是的，大家注意，吉姆和彭姆之间其实有一整条故事线，本该从这集开头就开始，并一步步铺垫到这个时刻的。是的。所以早些时候，大家还记得吉姆在打电话，他收到了彭姆的语音留言，当时她在外面和朋友们在一起。好吧，缺少的是这样一个非常可爱的片段：吉姆和彭姆在电话里聊天，他们在讨论《白宫风云》（The West Wing）。是的。而且珍娜，太可爱了。他们分享说他们一起在
on the DVD. So like they both have to hit play at the same time. I thought that was so cute. I have done that with friends. So cute. This is old tech romance, guys. In the script, this scene goes on and Jim says, are we on for the next episode tonight? Pam says, you know what? Can we raincheck it basically? You know, she says, I'm really tired. I think I'm just going to go to bed early. Yeah. She's had a big week at school. Yeah. So, you know, fine. But then later, what happens is she leaves Jim a message where she says, oh my gosh, my friends, they're dragging me out. They convinced me to go out. I'll call you later. Then Jim gets the butt dial from the bar from the bar where she's having a great time. And then Pam leaves him a message explaining that
DVD上观看。所以他们必须同时按播放键。我觉得这太可爱了。我和朋友们也这么做过。太可爱了。伙计们，这是老式科技浪漫。在剧本中，这场戏还在继续，吉姆说，我们今晚还按计划看下一集吗？彭姆说，你知道吗？基本上我们可以改天再约吗？你知道，她说，我真的很累。我想我还是早点上床睡觉吧。是的。她在学校度过了一个很忙碌的一周。所以，好吧。但后来，发生的事情是她给吉姆留了一条语音，说，哦天哪，我的朋友们，他们硬拉我出去。他们说服我出去了。我待会儿再给你打。然后吉姆接到了来自酒吧的误触电话，她在那里玩得很开心。然后彭姆给他留了一条语音，解释说
she did not get home until eight in the morning. So she was too tired to watch West Wing, but she went out with friends till eight in the morning. So that is really why Jim spirals for a second and is going to drive to New York. Yeah. That's why Roy's comment really took root, you know, because he's like, well, wait a second. I kind of feel like she just blew me off for these people. I don't even know. Yeah. And we're just going to leave you hanging on that one, by the way. Jim drives back and, you know, we'll work this out in the next episode. Well, back at the auction, it's 614. Yeah. It's the deadline. Dwight looks over at Angela and Angela purposefully looks to Andy.
她直到早上八点才回家。所以她累得看不了《白宫风云》，但她和朋友们在外面玩到了早上八点。所以这才是吉姆崩溃了一秒钟并打算开车去纽约的真正原因。是的。这就是为什么罗伊的话真的扎了根，你知道的，因为他在想，等等。我感觉她简直为了这些我甚至都不认识的人把我晾在一边。是的。顺便说一句，我们要把悬念留在这里。吉姆开车回来了，你知道的，我们会在下一集里解决这个问题。好吧，回到拍卖现场，现在是6点14分。是的。截止时间到了。德怀特看着安吉拉，而安吉拉故意把目光投向安迪。
And Dwight is crushed. She's made her choice. She's made her choice. Well, there was a scripted Angela talking head that didn't make it in. That would have gone right here. And Angela says, I'm not the type of person who breaks engagements. You should go talk to Pam. Once again, Angela is going to throw Pam under the bus. Yeah. When it comes to questions about her personal life, she's like, wait, who can I distract with? Oh yeah, Pam. Dwight is like, Phyllis, Phyllis, someone has let the air out of all of your tires. Come look. And Phyllis goes outside and yes, her tires are all flat. And Dwight's like, no, no, no, no, I just needed an excuse to get you out here. And I love Phyllis's line. Like,
德怀特心碎了。她做出了选择。她做出了选择。好吧，剧本里原本有一段安吉拉的独白没有被剪进正片。本该放在这里的。安吉拉说，我不是那种会解除婚约的人。你应该去和彭姆谈谈。安吉拉又一次想把彭姆当挡箭牌。是的。当被问及她的私生活问题时，她心想，等等，我可以转移谁的注意力？哦对了，彭姆。德怀特喊道，菲利斯，菲利斯，有人把你的车胎全放气了。快来看。菲利斯走到外面，没错，她的车胎全扁了。德怀特说，不，不，不，不，我只是需要一个借口把你叫出来。我太喜欢菲利斯的台词了。就像，
why couldn't you have just said it? Why'd you have to do it? Yeah. But Dwight's like, what do I do now? What do I do now? The ultimatum passed. And that's when Phyllis is like, well, I think you have your answer. It's the end, Dwight. That's what happens. You got to let it go. Yeah. Dwight is furious with Phyllis. But then he has this moment when he's by himself. And he's like, you know, kind of like how dare her. She's so selfish. Here she was just trying to help me. And then he sort of hears what he's just said. She was just trying to help him. That's what motivates him to go in and bid on her hug and drive the price up. Ultimately, it goes to Bob Vance. And Angela is so confused. She's like, why is Dwight bidding on a hug with
你为什么不直接说呢？你为什么非得这么做？是的。但德怀特说，我现在该怎么办？我现在该怎么办？最后通牒时间过了。然后菲利斯就说，好吧，我想你已经得到答案了。一切都结束了，德怀特。事情就是这样。你得放手了。是的。德怀特对菲利斯怒火中烧。但他独自一人时，突然有了这样一刻。他心想，怎么能这样。她太自私了。她刚才明明只是想帮我。然后他听到了自己刚才说的话。她刚才只是想帮他。这就是促使他走进去为她的拥抱竞标并把价格抬高的动力。最终，这个拥抱归了鲍勃·凡斯。安吉拉困惑极了。她心想，为什么德怀特这么咄咄逼人地竞标一个和
Phyllis like so aggressively? It's his way of saying thank you, I guess. Yeah. Well, she's the big winner of the night. It goes for the most money because as it turns out, Michael can't find the spring to see tickets. Can you believe it? Oh, what could have happened to them? Where are they? He definitely had them all the time. He definitely had them. Even though we learned that, you know, they're not even touring right now. Well, there's a very sweet scene now between Michael and Holly where Michael does admit that it's kind of a gray area, whether or not he had the Springsteen tickets. A lot about Michael is too good to be true, she says. Well, and you know how Jen Salada was always ruining takes by laughing on set? Yes. All the time, especially talking heads. Well, Jen told me
菲利斯的拥抱？我猜这是他表达谢谢的方式吧。好吧，她是今晚的最大赢家。拍出了最高价，因为事实证明，迈克尔找不到斯普林斯廷的门票了。你们敢相信吗？哦，它们会去哪儿呢？它们在哪儿？他明明一直都有的。他绝对有的。尽管我们后来得知，你知道的，他们现在根本都没在巡演。好吧，现在迈克尔和霍莉之间有一场非常温馨的戏，迈克尔承认他到底有没有斯普林斯廷的门票其实是一个灰色地带。她说，关于迈克尔的很多事情都好得让人难以置信。好吧，你知道珍·萨拉塔总是因为在片场大笑而毁掉镜头吗？是的。一直都在笑，尤其是拍独白的时候。好吧，珍告诉我
that she totally ruined a take during the scene. She says the moment when Holly is trying to cover Michael's mouth and tell him, don't say it, don't say it. And then how Michael is sort of delighted by this. So he starts laughing and then Holly starts laughing. Jen said that it felt so real to her that she thought they had broke. So Jen started laughing and ultimately ruined the take. And Steve was like, why were you laughing? And she said, I thought you were breaking. And he said, no, we were just acting. And then they all kind of laughed at that. But she said that moment made it onto the blooper reel. It did. I watched it. It's on season five bloopers on YouTube. You can see Jen cracking up. The episode ends with a kiss. Michael and Holly kiss. More than once. There's a
她在拍这场戏时彻底毁掉了一个镜头。她说，当霍莉试图捂住迈克尔的嘴并告诉他，别说，别说。然后迈克尔对这一幕感到很高兴。所以他开始笑，然后霍莉也开始笑了。珍说这感觉对她来说太真实了，以至于她以为他们两个真的笑场了（break）。所以珍也开始笑，最终毁掉了这个镜头。史蒂夫就说，你笑什么？她说，我以为你们笑场了。他说，没有，我们只是在演戏。然后他们都为此笑了起来。但她说那个镜头最后还是进了失误花絮。确实进了。我看过。它在YouTube上的第五季花絮里。你可以看到珍笑到崩溃。这一集在吻中结束。迈克尔和霍莉接吻了。不止一次。有一个
little kiss, then a bigger kiss. You guys, they're at work. Yeah. And David Wallace is there. He's watching from a distance. This episode ends with him saying, no, I did not know that Michael was dating Holly. He doesn't seem happy about it. Yeah, he's not. I mean, look what happened when Michael dated Jan. Oh my gosh. But David, what you don't know is that these guys are soulmates. But this is going to cause some problems for this couple going forward. We have a lot of couples in crisis. Yeah. Season five. Dwayangela, Jam, Molly, or Heichel. What are we calling them? Heichel? Holly and Michael. Yeah. They're either Molly or Heichel. Heichel. Season five. Shaking it up, guys. Shaking it up. Well, there you have it. That's
小小的吻，然后是一个更深情的吻。大家，他们可是在上班。是的。大卫·华尔斯也在那儿。他在远处看着。这一集以他说的话结束：“不，我不知道迈克尔在和霍莉交往。”他对此看起来可不太高兴。是的，他很不高兴。我是说，看看迈克尔和简交往时发生了什么。哦天哪。但大卫，你不知道的是，这俩人是灵魂伴侣。但这会给这对情侣未来的发展带来一些麻烦。我们有很多陷入危机的情侣。是的。第五季。德怀特和安吉拉（Dwayangela）、吉姆和彭姆（Jam）、霍莉和迈克尔（Molly）还是海克尔（Heichel）？我们该怎么称呼他们？海克尔？霍莉和迈克尔。是的。他们要么叫莫莉，要么叫海克尔。海克尔。第五季。搞点事情啊，各位。搞点事情。好了，这就是全部内容。这就是
CryMaid. I certainly learned a lot this episode. For example, Groupon doing crazy surveys. Yeah, very crazy surveys. And we know the most expensive used tissue ever sold at auction that I could find. There could be more. There could be more. But as far as I could find that record goes to Scarlett Johansson. Congratulations, Scarlett. And in CryMaid, the most expensive item sold goes to Phyllis. Way to go, Phyllis. Way to go, Phyllis. I'd take that hug. That's a good hug. All right, guys. We'll see you next week. We'll see you next week. We hope you have a good one. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Irwulf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer
《犯罪援助》。我这一集确实学到了很多。比如，高朋（Groupon）做疯狂的调查问卷。是的，非常疯狂的调查问卷。而且我们知道了拍卖史上售出的、我能找到的最贵的用过的纸巾。可能还有更贵的。可能还有。但就我所能找到的而言，那个纪录保持者是斯嘉丽·约翰逊。恭喜你，斯嘉丽。而在《犯罪援助》中，拍出的最昂贵物品归菲利斯所有。干得好，菲利斯。干得好，菲利斯。我愿意接受那个拥抱。那是个不错的拥抱。好了，各位。我们下周见。我们下周见。希望你们过得愉快。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由厄尔沃夫（Earwolf）、珍娜·费舍和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍。我们的制作人
is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubico. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月的Stitcher Premium，请使用优惠码Office。本集尚无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。